[Music]
from a robot that folds laundry to a
toothbrush that cleans teeth in 10
seconds
lifestyle tools dominate the world's
largest consumer technology Show CES
opens this morning in Las Vegas and more
than 180,000 people from 150 different
countries are expected to attend more
than 4,500 companies from innovative
startups to industry powerhouses like
Samsung will showcase their products
Bryan Cooley from our partners at CNET
is at the CES in Las Vegas with some
cool gadgets to show us so let's start
with the folding mate you had me at a
gadget that will actually do laundry
folding for you I'm sold but show my
little guys we are conquering the
drudgery of laundry folding mate is a
$1,000 robot it doesn't look like a
person it's not that kind of robot but
it's a machine kind of appliance sized
and shaped and you feed clothing into it
most types of pants or tops and shirts
and some towels it can't do big sheets
or really big beach towels but it can do
about 25 foldings in about five minutes
which is about the same pace as a human
so what it does is take the drudgery out
and not necessarily make it go a whole
lot faster it's only part of the laundry
picture I wish in the future it would be
a washer and a dryer and a folder for
the thousand dollars but we'll have to
wait for that okay baby steps Brian
let's talk about the robot be honest
said she liked the robot that does
laundry I'm curious about the robot that
hugs this is the lot it's a contraction
of loving and robots the idea is and a
lot of folks will scoff at this but many
of the smartest robot companies I'm
seeing here including groove X are
saying robots need to be relatable even
before they are capable because if we
don't like these things and this one's
listening to me right now it's looking
at me it's gonna react to me as I do as
I live with it we're not gonna welcome
into our lives unless they have some
kind of a personality that we like so
this is about a $3,000 robot you say
well it's quite a bit of money because
it's loaded with sensors it's loaded
with intelligence inside of it it's got
a camera on top that I think could maybe
matter a little more elegant in the
future but that's where it is now
the
is covered with dozens of sensors when I
when I carry it and hold it and Stroke
in a certain way it remembers that it
learns its relationship with me the more
time you spend with it the better it
knows you and the more it'll become
attached to you and actually kind of be
around you more so it's a companionship
product more than one that's gonna you
know bring you a cup of coffee or close
a window you know three thousand dollars
is a lot of money but I think they're
awfully cute I don't like it yes and
they also suggest you might want to buy
two of them so they can share feelings
with each other yeah okay now on to the
next language which is that if you were
ordering a la baat it might get stolen
from your stoop before it ever gets to
you so how are people how were
inventions being used to stop that yeah
how many stories have we done about
package theft especially around the
recent holidays so a company called
Danby has something called package guard
it's an industrial plastic mailbox it's
black and kind of large it's not the
prettiest thing to put in front of your
house but maybe you could paint it and
the idea is it's kind of like one of
those commercial drop-off boxes for
FedEx or UPS you put something in it and
it can't be stolen out of that same
drawer at the top but the delivery
company has access to it and they're
working out those relationships with UPS
USPS and such and it also is a place
where you can put your return so it
waits on the porch until a valid carrier
has access to it to get it it's kind of
a simple idea but it does have sensors
in it the ability to use barcode to get
people access one time and a camera of
course like everything these days to
know who came near it and what happened
if it got tampered with I'm really
interested in the health and wellness I
understand there's a new toothbrush yes
this is really interesting from a French
company called why brush this is so
simple it's deceptively clever it's a
sonic toothbrush combined with a sort of
a mouth tray like you would get a
fluoride treatment with and all the
bristles of a brush that can do all your
teeth at once so you put this thing in
it vibrates you put it in one time I'm
not going to do it it does the top of
your teeth in five seconds you turn this
thing over put it in it does the bottom
teeth in five seconds and that's it
you're done and you did a really good
brush job as well
yeah yeah I wanted to see you doing what
you did yeah I did yeah the love you
thank you Brian